who goes after a girl significantly
younger than them is severely lacking in
their life and I I mean that confidence
wise I mean like they are falling short
in so many places that that is the only
place they can turn to to feel like they
have they have something on the scale of
power and it's I mean ultimately it's
predatory I mean there's just no way to
kind of because you're manipulating
someone who is not aware of what they're
giving you and it's unfair
so my question is why are men called
Predators for going for younger women
but women don't typically have that same
energy for women that go for younger men
I don't know because I think older women
also Prejudice honestly like if you're
dating someone that much younger they
have way less life experience they don't
know themselves as well like you know
how to like shape them like you know to
get them way easier what would you put
at Predator like what what's your what's
the age Gap that you would say Predator
is Kruger
it's a lesson negative word I don't know
if you want to see maybe
15 20 years 15 20 years and would you
say the age Gap um does it matter how
old the younger person is like if
they're 30 yes yes it does matter if
that if I think if they're under like 25
or if they're under 25 or like under 27
maybe yeah okay and then it's like 20
years yeah Prejudice is the wrong word
Predator is it yeah
Predator is the wrong word and should
never be used Predator is the word you
use when you're going after
yeah miners you are yeah you're you know
it isn't being predated as someone that
has kind of power over you no no no a
predator is someone who is seeking out
to do harm so whether where there are
adults who seek to do harm in a certain
way which I'll you know we can't stay on
here to children that is what is called
a predator a predator is not what was
described in that video if you were a
man of any age whether you were going
after a male or female child intending
to meet them to do what you're gonna do
that is a predator so on that video
Predator is the wrong word and it's
taken out of context and it of course
it's going to blow up on social media
and people are going to start people are
influenced by people like her and you're
going to start every time you see some a
couple out on the street or in a bar
you're going to turn around oh he's a
predator or she's a predator because
you've heard it on social media it's the
wrong word if you want to know what a
predator is
yeah it's definitely not that I don't
know if you're underage it's not
consensual if it's between two
consensual adults
must have a bit more intention than that
but I think she's saying I don't know I
don't know what you're saying because
I'm just thinking over the case like
you're you're 18. you have the same
rights that I do if you want to jump on
a car right now you can go do it if you
want to vote you can vote like we're
both adults you know I mean if if we're
talking about under 16 and all them type
of things then we can talk about a
different story but I I think it's uh
like like
um miss lady in front said you know I
think Predator is using the wrong center
yeah I think we I'm sorry but my real my
real question is I I don't see the same
energy for women yeah I mean even even
when you started they're like okay but
it's like on social media if a man says
I I like a girl that's significantly
younger he's shamed for it but women
aren't I agree yeah
um it is a bit I'm not gonna lie though
I think that in a girl's world if you're
dating a guy that is younger than you
you are a sometimes can be looked as a
bit weird like why are you going for
like those younger the news why not no
I'm just saying that's how it is usually
in the girls world and I think that the
difference stems from the intentions as
well usually I would say correct me if
I'm wrong I think generally a man that
goes for woman that is younger it'll be
for those reasons of like okay she's
less combative she's
um you know easier to mold and all these
things fine is that right wait whereas
if you're a woman and you're going for a
younger guy a lot of the time I feel it
might be for the energy
now they've got a whole woman so I think
like I think that the intentions may be
slightly different and that's why I mean
what they're getting at and I think
they're probably talking from experience
you can tell the look in their eyes when
you're when you're a young woman
especially if you're a pretty young
woman a lot of older men will approach
you and at that moment in time when
you're that age there's a lot of things
that you really just don't know in fact
you don't even know enough about men to
be able to navigate the world with these
sort of men after you so that's why they
would come and say use such a strong
word to describe it because actually at
the end of the day it is a little bit
twisted what about a girl that what is
it
but why don't we have that same energy
of young women that go after older men
for their money
predator
would you say that Leonardo DiCaprio I
would argue yeah
you have Leonardo DiCaprio dating 27
years old is crazy
I also you guys for younger men so it's
wrong for
let's say it's wrong for men in their
30s to go for 18 year olds I understand
why they would like the the submissive
um being cooperative and like less
bodies but why would an older woman in
their like 30s go for a guy who is like
20 like what feminine what benefits do
you get from going from what is she said
it's just just a stamina that's it do
you not want I'm the girls that actually
go for younger men I do not want a man
that can provide and be like a proper
leader I know there are some younger
guys but generally speaking men men
under 30 they can't really give you what
you want so I just want to know what I
would say they love you way harder if
they're younger because you're more
likely to be there one of their first
loves you know I mean like I think as
they get older the love gets a little
bit more like I've done this a thousand
times like well and it's kind of I mean
it's kind of a meeting strategy in a way
because it's like men have less actual
Capital when they're younger and then
women have less sexual Capital when
they're older so they kind of hit off
each other yeah and don't forget also
what the boy said earlier they're like
oh yeah she was so much more mature and
she was this and yeah I enjoyed it and
this so they appreciated her that's it
so it's nice yeah but what's the what's
the woman gaining I get them what the
man you get validated yeah we like nice
words we just want a man to appreciate
us
um no that's why don't forget that women
also went and they require a lot of
validation so sometimes when you go for
younger Monday he's able to give you
that but all these guys have just said
that they're only looking to like not
really like a long commitment with an
older woman because she has like too
much baggage and all of that so like
what is the older women getting out of
this if it's not just fine like if it's
if she's looking for a long time
commitment like what is she finding with
these young men that don't want a long
time coming with an older woman yeah
would you say it's more companionship
yeah because so I'm gonna ask you
because you actually date younger bad
um yeah it's companionship and I won't
judge a young man my I've said it
already earlier on my ex was a lot
younger than me and age was totally
irrelevant
um you there are some gaps there are
things that he won't know and I won't
know and then somewhere you sort of just
meet in the middle but you get
companionship you you know I I was in
love we were I could say we were
genuinely in love you know I'm not going
to talk about the reasons we broke up
but yeah we were together four years and
that was with someone younger than me I
had companionship I had friendship I had
someone that understood me I had love I
had someone that looked out for me he
was actually a great cook
um I'm a bit lazy at that
um you know I used to go over to his
home and there was always food food
waiting for me not because I couldn't
you know go in the kitchen and make
something it was a real relationship so
everyone experiences something different
I think we've just got too many
stereotypes is oh you can't go out with
a younger man or you can't go out with
someone old man so you might tell me oh
I can't go out with someone that's 60 or
70. but what happens you know if I'm
attracted they're a nice man the
relationship is nice they're a good
person to me yeah the companionship is a
big word so to me it doesn't really
matter you have to it's something that
we all said here before
you have to and you said it particularly
it it depends on the actual person so if
I'm gonna have a relationship I mean I
don't want a fling I don't want to be
I would want to be with a man that's
just going to fling his bits around
um to put it politely it doesn't matter
how old you are obviously we all have
age restrictions but if I like you we're
attracted you respect me
you know you have love for me you're my
friend you're my companion you look out
for me you're a man you're a man you're
a leader you know how to look after me
it doesn't really matter if you've got
all those qualities
I'm Gonna Be With You
how no never mind the age some people I
know that men I think mature a little
bit later we will know that but what
happens when there's us individuals who
are the right one for you
I just have a question now like yeah of
course um you know obviously you think
that way now when you was like in your
late
um late 20s or like early 30s did you
think the same way like would you still
look for like a younger guy in that same
companionship role or you is this a
recent thing where you decided no no
nothing nothing is recent My Views have
never changed
um just a man has to be a good man
someone that wants to
look after me but can I just ask would
you seek out a younger man actively
actively actively know but if one
crossed my path and they happen to be
you know let's say I'm just going to get
thrown number out here if one crossed my
path and all of a sudden I met them and
and they I said how old were you and
they told me let's say for example
between 25 and 30 I'm not all of a
sudden going to turn around and say I'm
sorry I can't date you because your age
they might be the right person for me
yeah what about like an 18 year old like
if you were just out there on an 18 year
old couch and was like oh you're a
beautiful woman so so there's a hard cap
too yeah there is no I wouldn't okay no
no it's kind of interesting because you
kind of contradict yourself yeah no I
understand I understand I understand
what we mean and talk about
contradictions so we all have age limits
and we've all talked about it here
tonight and whilst I'm talking about yes
I will date a younger man I still have
my limit so I don't think that's me
contradicting myself I'm saying yes I'll
dated a younger man but I'm capping a
limit just like everybody else so I
don't think I'm I'm being contradictory
I just wanna
excuse me I just want to add um so
um in terms of my experience with women
yeah
I've never actually been in a
relationship with a woman that's younger
than me
and what I
hearing these discussions for me to the
two key words of the two takeaways are
you for maturity I think it goes in both
directions
um so I think for me I I presented
myself
has been a lot more older than I then I
guess in terms like the barometer of men
my age
and that's sort of what a lot of women
responded to and then once I'd
filled my age
in comparison to the the age that they
had the mental image that they had of me
it sort of I don't know just sort of
made something inside them just go a bit
I don't know I'm a bit addicted to me in
a certain way
um
so I just think I think it goes both
ways because you're saying earlier about
the 18 year olds and the 32.
maturity doesn't necessarily have a
fixed age if someone carries themselves
as like a 25 year old or 42 year old and
stuff more often than not weak kind of
like connect with that as opposed to
checking people's ID cards so
um that was just my my takeaway for that
it's all what society and people around
us say is the right thing to do it's
it's it's almost like saying I can't be
your friend unless you eat chalk mint
chocolate
you know everyone has to eat meat mint
chocolate if you want to be connected to
me because that's what Society that's
what the news tell us to do that's what
social media tells us to do that's what
your friends are telling you to do how
about what you want to do and how
sitting down with yourself and thinking
actually is this right does it work is
that the right person for me or am I
only doing what Society
expect me to do have you as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible